[Música]
es uno de los complejos de favelas más
grandes de Río en este campo gracias a
da Silva sale dos veces por semana para
entrenar enérgicamente a sus alumnas
bien hecho maiza genial en total una 60
adolescentes de entre 6 y 18 años vienen
aquí para demostrar que pueden ser tan
buenas como los hombres en este barrio
donde la cultura machista es un duro
contrincante graciara utiliza el balón
como herramienta de emancipación antes
de despedirnos nos encontraremos para
comenzar un poco Ok quedó embarazada a
los 16 años y ahora quiere guiar a estas
jóvenes hacia un futuro mejor que el de
la maternidad temprana
cuando te conviertes en madre muy joven
creo que lo más difícil es no poder
tener la energía suficiente para
alcanzar tus sueños
ves muchas madres adolescentes en el
barrio
sí muchas Y tú qué piensas eso molesta
porque
son muy jóvenes para tener hijos
este entrenadora de fútbol da lecciones
de educación sexual sin tabúes en un
país muy religioso donde el aborto es
ilegal
es fundamental decirles lo importante
que es cuidar su cuerpo y su higiene
personal como niña como mujer decirles
que tienen la libertad y la fuerza para
decidir lo que quieren para decir sí
quiero tener relaciones o no No quiero
entre sus alumnos se encuentra pérula de
6 años su madre Ana la tuvo a los 14
años y ahora trabaja como secretaria en
un hospital cercano
quiero que crezca normalmente que no
pase por lo que yo pasé que no tenga
prisa por enamorarse y hacer el amor
como yo que no se convierte en madre
Demasiado joven como yo y es un deporte
que le encanta jugar las estrellas de
Mandela tienen como objetivo crear
conciencia desde el principio para
desmentirla y persexualización a la que
se ven sometidas con frecuencia las
jóvenes de las favelas un reto diario
para graciara aquí el manguiños aún no
existe un programa gubernamental de
atención a la niñez y la adolescencia y
de planificación familiar